did I tell you how an ex retaliated by
eating my pet fish I don't like that
it's the same guy it's the same roast
beef guy actually when we broke up in
prison like what's going on no he's a
really successful guy understand how
every week there's some new horrifying
thing it and she's like did I tell you
and we I'm and we think she did we go
she's like did I tell you I'm we like
probably yeah and then it's
never this show is sponsored by
betterhelp become your own soulmate
whether you're looking for one or not
visit betterhelp.com TR Tuesday today to
get 10% off your first month that's
better help
hp.com sltr Tuesday what up slugs I am
on the road I'm so excited I will be
next in Denver Colorado February 17th
and 18th or whatever that weekend is my
website is weird right now my next Annie
wooden friends last night was so fun um
my next one is I think February I cannot
read these dates I don't know what is
wrong with my website I'll also be in
Vancouver um and then in March I'll be
in Fort Worth Texas I'll be in
Albuquerque New Mexico which I can't
wait to go to Washington DC and then I
reschedule Jacksonville for the end of
June go to Annie letter.com shows can't
wait to see you hi slugs I have the most
exciting news ever tickets for drugstore
June are on sale now for Los Angeles and
New York we are playing in Select
theaters only in those two cities
starting February 23rd we really want to
sell those out so you can get pre-sale
tickets at drugsto j.com and thank you
so much to everyone who's already been
supporting the film I can't wait for you
to see all the cameos that are not in
the trailer and I don't want anyone to
spoil it for you and then we'll be
opening expanding Nationwide March 1st
but New York and La get your tickets now
at drugstore j.com and then this Friday
this very Friday I will be in Portland
that's right we had to reschedule cuz
you guys had an ice storm and you kept
messaging me is the ice storm going to
affect the show I like I no we don't
have ice storms we do and they're in
Portland Friday February 2nd I will see
you guys at the Aladdin Theater get
tickets at Esther on
ice.com sluggy sluggy we're so excited
we're doing our second live show we had
so much fun at the last trash Tuesday
live it was I mean the Lord wants us to
have a live show I know the Lord hands
us everything we're going to be in Los
Angeles at the Regent Theater February
13th get your ticket at the link below
we have a lot of fun stuff planned and
we cannot wait to see you guys and we
can't wait for you to show up with your
interesting lives that will take the
show in very crazy places like if you
weren't there last time you blew it I
don't want to be too shameful but like
you really blew it and it was like
unmatched uncrazy but this one is going
to be even better um we also have a VIP
option where we just sit with you
literally face to face and we just
answer any question you have and it's so
cute it's so intimate at Regent Theater
January 13 February 13 I'm sorry region
theater Feb 13 the day before Valentin
it's going to be one year from last week
two weeks don't listen to these fools
we'll see you guys
there yeah I know Benji loves to talk
about that how little my penis would be
if I was a guy but is his big it's
actually huge oh that makes a lot
that explains the personality I hate
when people I don't want to have I don't
I like it when shitty people have small
penises it makes me sad when shitty
people have big penises it makes me sad
if shitty people have a small penis
because then you know that's why they're
shitty but there's a reason then when
when people come in just already fully
stacked and then they are terrible to
the world I've never met a big penis
attached to a man that I go this is a
great man I really haven't
I've had I've had monsters with monster
and I've had like painfully nice loser
guys with big you know what I mean where
their energy just sucked and they didn't
know how to own the there was never like
a medium ground bir really you just eat
a regular size penis speaking of big
penises I saw my ex this
weekend my exes I'm so excited to talk
to you guys about this so I went to
Austin I had the most healing trip of my
life that's right I spent quality time
with two ex-boyfriends and it was like
incredible did you go into a $3.1
million condo no I didn't you go I did
not go to his place no I so I went to I
feel like as a pregnant woman this would
be the safest time to go to an ex's home
that's when they want to have sex with
you the most I would think cuz then they
know they can't get you pregnant oh that
is true no everything like okay so um it
probably the episode probably came out
last night but I did Kill Tony which so
I saw Tony and redband who for years
I've been seeing like people will send
me on Reddit Esther Tony Esther and I'm
like yeah they were my boyfriends for a
year of course I did and it was just so
it makes it sound like you had like a
Kila relationship with them where they
were your boyfriends at the same time no
no no I love how we call it a Kila
relationship but that's not wrong out of
the three of us out of the three of
usate but I saw them and it was like
okay it it was there was just something
healing about it like we all we talked
so much about our past together and like
they have gotten so colossally
successful so basically if you don't
know my two exes started after literally
right after we all broke up at different
times they started a podcast together
and it's like one of the biggest like in
the last 68 months it has become
ginormous it used to be called kill
Esther but then they forgive her
they sold out two Madison Square Gardens
and it's also really nice to know that
now that they're both so rich and I'm
still like I'm really glad with whose
Seaman is inside of me so well now you
can kind of own the relationships more
that now that they're doing so well what
do you mean own them more now well now
you can be like you don't have to be
like we're not going to talk about this
right now no I've always been like I've
always had a it's always been positive
but I feel like it's the most positive
now I think as I hadn't seen them in so
long and I'm pregnant and it was just
really fun to like see how successful
they've become and I feel so proud of
them like I talked about this a little
bit on kill Tony but like when I met
Tony he was cashing his checks at a
check cashing place and when I found out
he was working there he was cashing
checks for everyone when I found that
out I like I went full Karen cuz he was
paying like a high percentage of every
check just to a check cashing place I
freaked out I took him to Chase Bank I
go Tony why don't you have a bank
account he's like they won't give me an
account Banks were denying him a bank
account I I walked him into Chase Bank
I'm like you give this man an account
and they're fighting me they're telling
me no and I did not leave the bank until
they gave him an account I still don't
know what his Shady history is that they
wouldn't do it without me fighting but
you didn't even know what you were
fighting Forest I almost feel maybe it's
a pregnancy I just feel this maternal
thing where like I got him his first
bank account he's still using it he's
selling out Madison Square Garden now it
just was like this beautiful moment and
just to see Brian Red Man like have such
a huge success but he he was always
successful like he literally co-created
or he started the Joe Rogan podcast but
I'm not going to say it like healed me
that my other ex won't talk to me but it
was we're on our
way that other X is not selling out
Madison SC he's not you're right so the
ones that count and the ones that help
me promote my movie on their show that
they they're good wait this is a good
topic the ones that count I mean I think
all girls have a list of the ones where
we want to talk about and the ones we're
like no let's bury that forever we will
never me best revenge is having them not
count how do we get there like okay so I
had one guy I'm they're like such losers
well it's not even that it's like so I
had this boyfriend who um cheated on me
and it was annoying and he moved then he
moved to LA it was it was just like it
was annoying it was annoying it was like
I'm allergic to condoms it was just like
you know it's just like this is annoying
yeah um but then years later when I
moved to LA we like hung out again and I
made out with him once but he was
wearing his invisaline and I found that
very disrespectful um that's right this
right disgusting but he was like you
know I went to this Chinese medicine
doctor and she really helped me like
realize like how what hor how horrible
it was what I did to you and I was like
oh I wasn't like in love with you I
don't care it was just annoying and that
was like the best revenge of my life
that is yes cuz I was like what I was
like don't waste your time I do I do
Wonder um because there are when people
bring up certain people that I've dated
and some of them I'm super dismissive
about where I'm like oh he didn't count
and so there are those and I think
everyone has a list of the counts and
the and the don't counts that's actually
so real I would never have him I I hope
to God he never finds out that he
doesn't you know he doesn't count but
like there are some people where I'm
like oh that was just an ineter yeah I
have like two that are coming to M where
I'm like that wasn't like a real I guess
it was an early days situation ship but
it wasn't like a real I can't imagine
well I mean I had a lot of those but I
can't imagine like I there's not one
ex-boyfriend that I could imagine giving
me a call and being like I'm so sorry
like I don't give a [__] yeah like
they're all at this point situationships
as far as I'm concerned I don't give a
fck about any of them I just there's
something about I don't know what it is
how I was brought up what what's wrong
with me me I love to like have a strong
connection with an ex that is like so
but you have to be 100 million per over
them and it has to just be it's just it
was just this warmth that I felt talking
to them and again maybe it's because I'm
still like trying to fill this hole from
my high school ex who blocked me on all
channels but there's just like this
familial warmth there it's it's
different than friendship it's you know
we're not going to talk we're not going
to hang out but like when I see you I
want it to be so warm and happy and like
catch up hear how your family is doing I
don't know to me that's just like the
perfect ex relationship and also it
could I was going to say like oh if they
did something really bad like maybe
that's never possible but with enough
time I I I'm just thinking like I think
anything is possible you hear that High
School X I won't say your name out of
respect but I know where you work I
didn't know how many kids you have um
he's got kids yeah I did cute I did a
refresh Deep dive on him when I was home
for a couple holidays and my mom and dad
did drive me past his house and I said
that once the movie comes out that's a
little bit about him I'm going to stop
that's it that's a period to the
sentence yeah you should get a billboard
of the movie right outside his face I
mean obviously I'm thinking that as well
he won't go by anymore but he'll have to
go by drive by you um I think that like
what I have
trouble what I'm realizing now is that
there are some people who are so
adamantly against being friends with
exes and I think that has to come from
their own like personal experiences you
know I mean everyone everything how we
feel is really just a projection of what
we've been through right because there
are people who are like you know
absolutely not that relationship should
be dead it's over no friendship and I
wonder where that those hard and fast
rules like come from being hurt I would
think but I mean it's like you've been
hurt I've been hurt but it's like Tod's
like a no don't be friends with the
people I I just don't want to be I just
really I I really think I've grown so
much and I I think I had such unhealthy
relationships because I was so unhealthy
that it's like I just don't even relate
to who I was in those relationships and
I have no interest in revisiting that I
forgive that and I give Grace to that
girl that I was but I have no interest
in having anything to do with that but I
think it it like we have if I had like a
job and we work like I wouldn't it
wouldn't be like yeah it's not I'm not
taking this job cuz but it's just like I
don't I'm definitely not like seeking
out an act randomly it's more like if I
see them I want I love that it's warm
and happy but you're like to if I was
seeking it out that would be like weird
a little well I just don't I don't think
I need like like um I don't know I feel
fulfilled with Todd like I just don't
yeah and I don't need like closure
doesn't come from another person I
really don't believe it comes from
another person it's like yourself thing
I've said to my sister 3,000 times while
driving by your ex-boyfriend's house and
livid he won't just peek out the say
that louder you get closure from
yourself only and I even though I'm I'm
sorry I'm a hypocrite because my sister
has been saying like I just want closure
I just want this last conversation with
this guy and I'm like you get closure
only from yourself but then now I have a
friend breakup going on in my life that
I am spinning and wanting closure from
so I do understand it but I keep telling
myself there's no last conversation
that's going to like give me the answers
like I have to find it within it it is I
will what you need me to
say
Annie let's let's have it right here
right now yeah cuz I think that um it
can be two things it's really that that
person could say something that could
offer you some further understanding of
why they acted the way they did or
you're really just like cuz with some
people you'll never get that it's not in
their wheelhouse to even want you to
understand and they don't even know they
don't know it's just they also just
might not like you it's true they also
just might not want to face what they
did or said and the easiest way to do
that is to hide I don't know I mean what
would what is your advice for me that
I'm like I'm pissed I think about it
more than I'd like to and it's not
healthy for me to be pregnant and
thinking about this like person who feel
like effed me over what is your advice
cuz I you know all I want to do is call
this person and be like you did this I
heard this you did this you're saying
this like that's scary I don't like that
like I want to say all these you cut the
cord like you cut a cord and then it
really doesn't matter what they say
because you have nothing to do with them
have you already done those things have
you have you already confronted that
you've done this so I think that if
what's bugging you is that you haven't
said that I don't think you're yearning
for the conversation it's just that
you're yearning to get that off your
chest yeah I am to feel heard yeah do
you have to see this person no I don't
actually I mean every time you think
about that person I would just be
thinking about how exciting is that
you're having a daughter and how much
fun you're going to have with your kid
and just focus your energy on positive
because who cares it's like you're what
you're wanting to do is you're wanting
to control The Narrative of this friend
breakup or whatever and you're mad if
they're talking [__] on you but it's
like if I think I know who you're
talking about I OB you it really doesn't
matter what they say cuz they're it's so
sad you are friends with them to begin
with but and it's really time I think to
kind of move on from the low Vibe energy
you were you block you literally blocked
three years ago you were ahead of the
game what is wrong with me I you're
distracting yourself just be happy you
have so much to be happy about and
you're used to not being happy so you're
like you have a pattern of like being
upset about something or you had him be
upset and you're watching him be upset
and was ENT aining you so he is like a
negative thing that you were like poking
and it was funny you would like I can
guarantee you it's only going to amuse
him and feed something in him that you
come to him with sincerity so easy it's
just so easy it actually is not hard s
it's literally a choice where you just
go I'm not going to like let my brain
upset you could be obsessing over like
creative things right you're right now
you know what it's a it's intrusive
thoughts it's intrusive thoughts and
they're they're intrusive this is not a
person That was supposed to be near us
like I want to feel bad but I also don't
cuz I'm just like there's nothing to
feel you guys are right someone who
would do these things you guys are right
about them and I know I would more
evaluate who you are to be because
that's we have control over go why do I
why did I need this type of
entertainment why couldn't I think habit
I think you get into a habit with
someone and then they feel like a
comfort and it's fun cuz there was a
crew there was a crew and it's kind of
the same pattern with no I think that
that um one's a little more
malicious I just think that I want to
look within and be like why what is
missing from my life that I would have
people in my life like that and I'm
going to look at it as like a gift that
I wasn't able to end this relationship
this friendship and thankfully they did
I have a genuine question for you aser
are you trying to single white femil me
yes how did you who told you
okay I actually like almost feel bad
admitting this I think that this is my
cycle it's like I wanted I I had
romantic feelings for you and now
they've shifted and I want to be you
because this weekend I did not so I went
to Austin with Bobby and listen to this
listen to this listen closely okay so I
went to Austin with Bobby and I didn't
realize who was also coming on that trip
was none other than kila's whole crew at
tigerbelly Gilbert and George and so I
ended up spending like basically 72
hours as Kila with Bobby George and
Gilbert and I had the most fun no I've
ever had like it was the best time and
all I kept thinking was like this is
kila's RO like I was just like I'm her
now this is it I it fits so I fit in so
seamlessly this is perfect
and I'm so like I can't believe that's
your crew it was so the Dynamics were
right just in every single way the
betral that makes no can I say something
that makes me sad because I've spent
time with them and I felt that same
thing and I thought it was special like
I thought I was special you've been on
the road with us it is really so sweet
it is so sweet but I now I'm like I
guess that's how they are with everybody
and I'm like [__] funny G
Gilbert Gilbert is unbelievable a
Gilbert on tiger belly no but I've
threatened for years oh I really thought
that happened I was like that is pretty
gangster that's pretty fun that's pretty
fun and his wife rolles too Gilbert's
wife is the star of the entire family
she's best and I will take this moment
to absolutely establish myself as an
original founding father of tiger belly
why you ask I have receipts how did
Gilbert meet Kila through my college
friend Jenna how did Jenna meet kalila
through me so my lawyers will be
reaching out I think I'm old I mean this
single white femaling is so deep like it
stems back from like you see how she's I
posturing be careful you end up with a
pump in your eye oh that's right this a
great movie you guys it's just basically
a woman trying to become another woman
but there were initial like romantic
feelings right kind of I haven't seen it
in a while but I do remember that
feeling of being like wait is she in
love with her and they're just not
saying it I L brid Fonda was she gave us
so much thank you for being my standin
it was really fun thank you for allowing
it honestly I'm really um um slightly
threatened but also okay with it but
speaking of um circumcision I've
completely changed my mind because I
grew up in a country right where if
you're not circumcised you're
humiliated like your whole life if
you're an uncircumcised adult they will
call you this thing called pisot and you
are
undatable like you just not a man you're
not circumcised you're not circumcised
similar to like you know I know like um
I think it's Jewish Filipino what other
like Catholics right I genuinely think
the idea of circumcising like my own son
and chopping off a bit of his penis
without consent really makes me sick
like how did we get here is it was it
because of religion it's getting less
and less common but they say it's still
around 50/50 but that's call me a
zookeeper but I enjoy an anater
myself oh there's more yes it's more
dick I've never oh can I just see it's
more skin but it's rubbing it's you
don't have jul can I just say this also
I know that you have a booty but it's
not the
same there's a ribed it's a whole thing
it's like fun to yeah it's fun no
because um I also think that it takes
away the joy of masturbation because
when you have it's almost like having a
built-in pocket because when you jerk
off when you have foreskin you're just
the dick goes in and out of the for skin
and when you blow them it is so much
easier little animal you make a little
animal ballon you make a balloon you
don't need Lube to go back and forth on
the shaft you literally just use the
forkin I like to make it like a little
poodle tail like you like blow into it
and like I thought we were talking about
your unborn son this is really switched
right turn um you have to worry about
that BV though baby got to clean that
fromunda cheese out I are you for sure
like you would never circumcise cuz
you're no I would do whatever I I was
Pro but Dave was not pro but you know
Annie how you were talking about how um
the way you are born embeds into like
your trauma and the the young life that
you live I think that something must
happen to the brain when you are
something is being yeah when you are
physically when a part of you being
physically removed especially in that
part of your body remember we don't
remember
anything what
yes you're born with a brain it's it's
taking bra all of your problems like
your problem with this guy right now and
whatever your psychological issue is
with this person from from when you were
circumcised as a child no it's from when
you were like under seven years old like
your brain is like fully like all of
your like negative stories go into your
brain before you're seven years old well
it does make sense
that cuz I did find out recently that
basically when I was a baby my dad like
literally I can't remember we talked
about this on here already but like did
nothing so I'm wondering if there's some
he didn't daddy didn't do skin to skin I
guess he did but it's just my mom did my
mom is a person who does everything and
so I don't know if there's some weird
like Dad was there but was just there my
dad yeah my dad was like working all the
time too but it's funny cuz I do
remember when we were kids like if my
mom went to go play rocketball my dad
was the one at home we called it
babysitting the dad was babysitting us
that's common yeah yeah Dad's
babysitting tonight but it wasn't like
Mom's babysitting the rest of the time
wait Annie how was New York I can't
believe you went to New York fun I was
like sick though I was like I was just
trying to keep it together the whole
time but it was really fun but it was
still really fun but it was just like I
hate not being 100% it's just so
frustrating I'm so like hyper and Manic
and I love being crazy and it's just
like did you eat anything fun or like no
I couldn't really do it I was like yeah
I stayed at Tim's place and Tribeca it
was fun but I I'm starting to get really
really proud of myself that I am like so
good at cultivating the best green room
hangs on this earth like my shows that I
book like the Annie wood and friends and
then this one I did with Bonnie but it's
like I just like booked like all of my
friends it was me Mark Norman Tim Dylan
Bonnie and then did you stay with Tim
mhm what was that like it was fun it so
great
yeah I've stayed with him at two out of
no three out of four of his houses okay
I will check those boxes fun it's been
very fun i' I've just not had a reason
to sleep over in LA but we did uh so we
were in the green room and then Shawn
Patton was there and then Santino jumped
like dropped by it was just like it was
just such good laughs just so many old
stories I had that like the week before
naori was in town with Ari and it was
like just like it's just so fun these
people that I came up with that are
doing doing so well it's just so amazing
like barazi just posted a picture of him
doing like this huge Stadium or Arena I
don't know the difference and like Jimmy
fallam was bringing it's just like I
used to do Eastville open mics with them
you know it's just very exciting and
it's really fun and just really and my
feels about it and then last night I had
an Annie wooden friends and it was um
Tim Natasha who's just a [__] angel
she's so beautiful K who's like weirdly
so I'm like K did you used to be F like
I don't remember what you looked like
before you had like a chisel face does
he still have um the same um ripped body
or did he lose it after he looks like a
no he's so ripped and I'm like were you
fat like I'm like I don't remember what
you looked at but I don't remember
chisel he wasn't even fat he was just
like not in shape and then like Marvel
and then he so crazy get and then it was
like and then Whitney stopped by it's
just like my shows people that aren't on
come stop like it's just so fun I've
been thinking about this a lot like the
comedy clubs are such a good example of
a third place which like a third place
is basically somewhere you can show up
you don't have to plan it but like you
might see people that you know and
because basically like maintaining adult
friendships is really really difficult
which I fully relate to like you have to
like make these plans drive across town
whatever and so sometimes they block
you what you're talking about is like
one of the most like fueling Community
Building like brain empowering
at
you're that is what I'm trying to
manifest more into my life in 2024 like
that's going to make me feel good that's
going to be good for my health it's it's
just going to it's like I think for a
long time like relationships and
friendships were something I just didn't
prioritize and I'm like no I want to do
what I will drive I will show up like
cuz that what you're saying is magical
it's a drug it's better than drugs it's
crazy and it's like and then on top of
that we're all like working on these new
acts and these and so it's like fun
we're like laughing we're going over
bits it's just like so it just was so
fun and I think like if you don't have
this job right and you don't have this
sort of like social outing thing it's
like maybe you're on a bowling league or
it's like sports or it's something
that's like keeping even the coffee shop
I go that's a third place for me like I
go there the bries know me I know them I
think even like wherever you go to work
out like I'm not working out at home
over not on the list anymore like I need
to go I need to see people I don't even
care if I've never seen them before I
will be like I will start I like I like
your bag what's up like I think that's
supposed to be one of the KE thir place
is for me what did you say a third place
is Right Aid for me Donna my girl I love
you it is a key to longevity yeah is
daily um social interactions with people
who aren't your close friends and family
well I told you my dad always says
whenever I'm depr impress my dad's like
go talk to strangers I'm like that's
literally how I got molested thanks Dad
but um but it he we're just guess my
family were extroverts me I see why you
do that now cuz you always whenever I'm
out with you I'm like the where did
Annie go oh she's 30 minutes deep into a
conversation at the register and I'm
just like I thought we were hanging out
but I see the beauty in that now and
that's something that I don't lean
towards and I think this is part of like
the pregnancy effect of like there's
just like a new sense of loneliness in
me and I my theory is that it's like
because I have the baby in me I being
alone is a lot scarier cuz like my body
knows I need Community to help me
survive and so I'm just prioritizing
this experience that you're sharing for
sure and so fun you hopefully it won't
be with only my exes like it was this
weekend I need others too I can't
believe you don't go to the
apartment um I um I thought about you I
was like reading this um study on like
um have you heard of the still faced
mom no but that's my mom yeah so I know
like it's resonating I think Dr Drew
might have touched on it a little bit
but it's basically like I think I think
he called it like second order
representation but Bas basically they do
studies on on um moms not reacting to
their babies like bids for attention in
a way that the baby can understand so if
they're like communicating with a flat
AFF effect rather than being animated
apparently it causes a lot of
psychological problems for for babies or
children and I thought about your mom
cuz your mom is very stoic yeah it's
like a finished thing there's no there's
no movement there's no like the tone is
always the same she's like AI M was your
mom like this 100% it's so really guys
my mom it's the most annoying thing you
know what I was like I was remembering
this [__] [__] I remember like in
high school I'd be like Mom do you want
to like hang out this weekend and she's
like oh I'm going to the art museum with
Max's girlfriend and I'm
like can I go to the art museum why are
you taking some other like it would be
like she would literally like show it to
other people but I'm telling you it's
cuz she's adopted and she has issues
with like motherdaughter relationship
because she has issues with having been
adopted was she like sort of like a
flatter personality she would look she
would look she can be animated for other
people she would look
i' be like you're looking at my ear
she'd be like she'd be like my eyes are
over
here this show is sponsored by better
help I have benefited from therapy so
much in my life and I'm so excited we're
talking today about Annie's therapy
Journey like I'm just so excited for her
because going deep with someone else and
getting that other perspective is so
important and you just can't do it alone
it is to me just like drinking water it
is something that I cannot go without it
is something that I've acknowledged I
absolutely need in my life and will
continue to do and if you're thinking of
giving therapy a try no better place to
start than better help it's entirely
online so it is designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule and it's super easy you just
fill out a brief questionnaire and they
match you with a licensed therapist and
you can switch therapist anytime because
honestly like let's be real like there
have been times where I've gotone into a
consult and I'm like I don't think this
person and I are a match and you can do
that very easily with better help for no
additional charge become your own
soulmate whether you're looking for one
or not visit betterhelp.com TR Tuesday
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com sltr
Tuesday are these things that either of
you felt um do you feel as though your
parent was aware of your
emotions
I don't think they had any time to deal
with my emotions or care about my
emotions were hold on did they recognize
your expressions of emotion as an
opportunity for intimacy and teaching no
no as an opportunity to be like my
daughter's
broken I'm just lack do in tolerant I I
I would say that just like upped the
ignore like channel it's like oh it's
she's doing more like we do less yeah
that's okay this one I for sure didn't
get did they listen with empathy and
valid your feelings I love you guys but
no did they help you learn to label your
feelings with words are you [__]
kidding me it's calling me a selfish
[__] labeling my feelings I don't know
actually yeah actually I had to guys I'm
doing EMDR am I saying it right isn't it
so great I haven't started that part yet
I just did the horrific timeline of
traumatic events oh my God which I I
really do I've done so much work on
myself and I am like I'm over this or
whatever I'm like there are stored and
trapped emotions inside me it was like
hor like my therapist is like a selfish
cont I'm like yes yeah I guess when you
say that I hear it as a joke well it's
funny cuz it's funny now and because my
parents here's the thing I did always
and she my therapist pointed this out
she's like she's like you're you did
always feel loved though I was like yes
cuz they always like apologize my
parents never like silent treated you
apologize to they would cuz they were
[__] it was crazy what they would do
so then but it would always I would go
up to my room and then they would come
up and apologize cuz my dad was like my
dad worked a lot on his anger like a lot
on his anger he didn't work on it in the
beginning of my life he worked on it
when I was like a teenager so it's like
so I did get but it was all he was mad
he was overwhelmed from work he would
come home and he would take it out on us
he just like didn't want to hear kids
you know and so but and obviously he
felt selfish and that's why I was being
called Selfish I feel like ignore was
the bigger like yeah I didn't get tactic
in my house it was like just kind of
ignore my in tactic in my house was
ignore until it gets too much and then
you just belt them and punch them okay
okay that also sounds like a joke but
isn't yeah but it's like no punch your
kids right in the mouth these things
that you're listing sound new to me like
advanced parenting it seems new right we
didn't have Instagram with the little
slides tell us more actually what emot
being emotionally available is like like
I want to give my parents a break
because and I'll always like I always am
so grateful to my dad because he was he
was beaten he was beaten he was beaten
he was beaten and he never laid a hand
on me and so I'm always so grateful for
that he really did like so he did break
some part of that c course and he like
and he manned up and he did the work and
he's so kind and so sweet now and
there's I have no I I really like I feel
so lucky that my parents have like done
all the work they've done because it's
just not it's not in my present I accept
my parents for what they're doing for me
now I think a big thing when I look back
on my upbringing and the grace that I
give is that like I came out nothing
like my mom and nothing like anyone in
her family and probably realistically
more like my dad and so I think she just
at certain points did not know how to
this was just so and especially she had
already had my sister my sister was much
like you know more calm and like them
prettier and prettier yes we all know
skinnier prettier bigger boobs yes hug
taller you forgot taller taller yeah
yeah um but so I also give Grace and
like I do feel a lot of just I'm so
grateful and I feel so close with my
parents and I think any par parent child
relationship is so complicated like I
think about you and what you've shared
on the show you've been so vulnerable
like your parents age Gap makes you
uncomfortable but it's still your dad
and you still love him and like that's
such an a perfect example of how
complicated it can be with a parent cuz
it's we're programmed to love our
parents we're not like that's asking a
lot to be holding a grudge over you know
like Dr Spock was like the parenting
book there was like a book that told you
how to there was a book and it was Star
Trek themed it was Star Trek theme it
said do this inside your daughter just
kidding don't wait what's the last one
cuz these are it's famously it was
written by a man but everyone says that
the wife wrote about wait what was the
last thing on that list cuz this list is
really res oh yeah set limits when you
are helping your child to solve problems
or deal with upsetting situations
appropriately well did they sure yanked
me out of the closet when I was
constipated and hiding cuz it hurt to
poop and said take a [__] you [__] um
so I guess that was a limit but also
there's a little bit of abuse like Todd
I'm always like to Todd's parents I'm
like you like ignored him just enough
he's such a perfect man like they just
did I don't know what it was the recipe
is so it's hard to pinpoint what the
recipe is they just did the right the
right amount of laughing and the right
amount of yelling and the right amount
of like I don't know what it was middle
childing his ass cuz I look at Dave and
he had such amazing healthy parents a
great upbringing and he's a great guy
but I know that part of what makes him a
great guy is not just that healthy
upbringing it's that he had a really big
nose and was made fun of and that
without that element he wouldn't be Dave
and that element makes him an amazing
person yeah and so it the what is the
recipe I don't know because you need
hardships right like someone you you
need some level of difficulty like they
say like for animals to thrive in any
environment you need um medium
disturbance not too much and not too
little and that's literally how the
strongest like animals like evolve it's
you need some midlevel disturbance so I
think a Sprinkle of trauma a Sprinkle of
bad things but mostly love feeling loved
is like I think a great
I also have heard that if you don't have
a traumatic childhood that's your
traumatic thing like not having trauma
also can read as like we got enough
therapy out there we're we just have a
lot we're social media has made it a lot
harder in a lot of ways I think because
there's like beauty standards there's
like this sort of like but what about
the swipes but there's the
swipes there's the swipes and there's
there's hearing other people's like
experiences like there podcast hello
yeah it's other
people learning that other people's exp
but even like think with parenting
there's like so many parenting Tik toks
there's so many like examples I yeah and
they're so [__] overwhelming and I
hate my algorithm right now I'm so
impressed to hear that you literally
went through the painful annoying ass
work of laying out a timeline for like
well she wanted me to do it as homework
and I said if you ever want to meet
again if you ever want to see me again
[__] you will be right here with me I'm
like I can't I need an
audience I need an audience that's what
I've been realizing too it's like with
all these like writing projects I'm
working on it's like I just I'm done
like shaming myself for not being
someone that wants to sit and write by
myself I just don't want to do it it's
just I'm a twin I'm sick of trying to
like reinvent how I learn and how I
express myself and I'm just like Embrace
who you are yes it's like I don't have
[__] time to go what am I going to go
back to college and it's just it's I I
like partners that makes sense you're a
twin you shared a womb with another body
um over the last few weeks I've been
trying to pinpoint things that cause me
um quick rage and rage that I cannot
like easily come back down from what do
I need to say to you too and I realized
one of the things one of the things that
really like will put me in an like I
mean a rage is if I cook for you and you
don't eat it while it's hot if you even
wait if I say hey dinner is ready and
you don't come running to the table it
will put me in a rage that
will cost maybe like at least a week of
not speaking cuz it's like the wasted
time you're like I I cook with so much
like love in my heart and I put so much
like thought behind it and when
someone's like yeah I'll be there let me
just finish this thing and then 30
minutes later they eat that thing it
nothing like ruins my day more and that
is really annoying to me I don't have
rage but it pisses me off c yeah that's
interesting can you express that to
people so they know like but then also
if people have something to do if I'm
cooking for someone it shouldn't really
be on my schedule I recognize now that
I'm not necessarily right I'm not right
for feeling this rage I should be
patient but it's just like you're not
going to eat it at its
optimal like I'm searching for something
I can relate to in this I will never be
cooking for anyone I I'm searching wait
I know what this is about though when
someone cooks for you though Annie um do
you come to the table right away you're
like no I'll be there in like 30 minutes
yeah no I wouldn't do that it's putting
effort into something and doing
something sweet and then feeling a
little disrespected I think that's what
I feel I think it's different for Kila I
think it's
that she is a perfectionist and an
overachiever and that's how she was
trained to be and so if the person is
not experiencing the food at the best
possible time then she's not going to be
perceived as the best that she did right
they're going to judge me based on what
the food tastes like when it's no longer
optimal at the optimal temperature and
then you're going to be like oh it was
okay versus well if you had eaten it 10
minutes prior and you can't microwave it
it's not the same it's not the same you
would have a gold medal though suar fish
this is you know this an argument for
this is an argument for talking with
your mouth full because I will be
talking but I'll also be eating and I
don't care if you think that's rude
because it's actually more rude to her
for me and I can't it's rude to me to
stop talking so you're saying no matter
what you're doing my mouth is moving so
food can go in no I I I think whoever
came up with a don't talk when your
mouth is full is like who the [__] cares
you know what parents that don't want to
hear you it's parents that want just a
break from you speaking that they're
just going shut the [__] up [__] one
second no I think it's there's this
whole crew of people who have manners
like wasps and stuff that we just aren
none of us I have been hanging out with
some wealthy people like wealthy like
people that were like born in wealth
that aren't in our weird
business it's different I'm trying to
Vibe high but it's do they have their
breath is better it's not a breath thing
it's like there's a politeness that I'm
not I'm trying to fake and I don't I'm
not comfortable in it it's just there's
just a level and they are bewildered by
me how old are they cuz like my dad was
very hardcore into manners cuz he was
born in 1924 and he was born into a very
like old money like affluent European
family right so my dad was very like I
the one thing he hated is to this day I
will still eat with one leg up like this
and it used to drive him crazy but I
used to Stand My Ground And I say well I
want to be comfortable when I eat so I'm
going to and my dad never let go of all
of his like etiquette values and I do
think like he was just cut from like a
Different Cloth in that way because he
was like forced to like learn some level
of like etiquette yeah I think there's
people who don't want you to chew with
your mouth open it's just none of us and
it makes that makes complete sense to me
there people that want us to not chew on
the mic it's like you know like my this
what I'm doing like for a living is my
dad's like absolute nightmare why
because when we had to leave the table
able to go to the bathroom I told you
guys this he what we would have to say
is you cannot say I'm going number two I
got to go to the bathroom you would say
may I pick up some flowers like that was
the code we would speak in code because
it was impolite to say I got to go take
a [__] like he was that guy your
upbringing it's just always it's like a
board game and you just it always twists
and turn it's always RIS and it's scary
and it's confusing like I don't know how
you I don't know how you got from point
A to point B I don't know either and I
think that's why I am somebody who lives
in maternity outfits even though I'm not
pregnant I am so sloppy I like not being
I I like not brushing my hair and it's
because my dad had that very like rigid
idea of like he was now you're single
femaling her I know that's totally what
I Rel cuz my mom was like super clean
like everything perfect and that's why
my like people my friends come over like
Esther that's why you're a slob it's
because your mom made everything perfect
everything with a coaster whatever and I
remember I went to our friend Jenna's
house in college and I saw she had a
wall in her bedroom that her mom let all
of anyone she wanted draw all so this
wall is covered in like writing and I I
just my jaw was on the floor like I
loved those rooms the people with the
chalkboard walls it wasn't it was just
no it was painted wall and people could
draw who paid for her deposit no I I
think they own their house oh okay o
I like I you don't I was not allowed to
if there was a thumb print on a wall in
my house it was like we tell you not to
touch the walls like it was a huge deal
and so the littlest thumb print what a
little thumb print that was so low to
the ground who's even going to see it
the Purity and the cleanliness that was
required of me has definitely swung me
in you just such a little s how to set
the table what I don't know I was a
waitress I still don't know which way
the [__] which side the forks on I
know how to set the table but in like I
think the Filipino version because we
eat with a spoon on the right hand and a
fork on the left I have to Google it
every time I no I just think you got a
you just you get the utensils you need
it doesn't matter where they are but I
think I got a little bit of both right
so like cuz my mom is OCD but I got the
shower three times a day part like the
so I'm I I appear sloppy but I'm so so
so so weird about like my mouth and like
the hygiene we're like sweaty we have to
make sure we don't smell yes I am always
very very sweaty I'm sweating right now
Jesus Christ I'm always sweating oh
after I did the timeline therapy my
sweat was down to my waist yeah are you
serious yeah it was down to my waist and
it was 1 hour this was like a big deal
yeah this like [__] came we haven't done
that part yet so I'm like EMDR is really
crazy my uh my sister-in-law does it
down in South Florida two people or gets
it done no she she is a practitioner
yeah so she she does it in South Florida
and I mean it's like it's a it's narly
like it is i' commend you for doing that
I'm excited I think my my first EMDR
session I hardly said a word I had an
initial like burst of memories and then
I was like too terrified to speak like
for the rest of the time and she was
like try this again next time is EMD
when you hold the buzzers yeah you have
different options you can hold the
buzzers you can there's multiple ways
but there's always some like bilateral
like stimulation because it connects the
two part of your brains it's what it's
hosted by Taylor
Thomasson are you doing that I don't
know you should do that to promote your
movie wait I don't get the joke though
cuz it's like a buzzer show it's just
like like I was raped Bing make sure you
have just one hand on the buzzer no um
yeah I have no clue what to be fun I had
this thought when I was about 40 ft
underwater um that was really maybe
people have like thought about this and
maybe they've said it time and time
again but I really had this like very
deep like rage another thing I was
rageful about about the fact that you
know when you were growing up when boys
would shame you for being like roast
beefy or your lips would hang too low or
they would like always mention and they
would Talk Amongst each other about like
the look of our vagina wait Annie what's
the OIC update it's been like a couple
months now we still going I'm I'm just I
don't know I'm oic's best candidate I
love it I lost 15 pounds no side effects
no side effects except joy
happiness clear mind and how often do
you get it I do it I administer it
myself once a week but I took a week off
um cuz I was doing iasa and I was fine
like I think I could go off a bit I
think it did help me with my patterns
stuff like they're like you have to
stand out forever I'm like not me is
there like an energy change or a shift
or are you still like do you want to
work out or yeah it's like so easy to
work out I don't know what anyone's like
it's just I'm like am I on a placebo or
something I don't know because I'm just
having the great and it's like I just
feel great I don't feel any there's no
negative side effect I'm hungry I just
don't overeat so it's just eat like if
you were just like a normal person
without like a disorder not that I have
like that much of a disorder but I just
you know I don't have like the emotional
connection to food it's just I just eat
it I enjoy it it's so easy because you
and I have that share that same problem
where it's like we don't eat for to get
full right we eat like past full right
we eat for taste you think you're the
only ones who has that issue come on
yeah so we definitely I know you really
gained a
bunch so did does it just help you stop
when you're TCH your stomach
yeah it's so cute Esther but does
touching it do anything for you like you
it's so like smooth and cute it's like
firm right that's like what's different
this is the firmest my stomach has ever
been just to feel like something around
like that is like so mov I feel movement
yeah it's not really kicks it's just
like she'll just randomly be like I'm
like okay but yeah I love feeling
movement it's my favorite thing they say
be kind to your mother she's the only
one that felt your heartbeat inside her
a like cute and yet I'm still a huge
[__] to my mom well you know we're the
meanest to the people we love the most
yeah yeah I know it's like that thing
where you're like you I can talk sh my
mom but you can't I will say there was a
huge shift the last 10 days I'm 30 weeks
right now and I would say around 28 29
weeks the
hunger which you guys will relate to has
become binge eating disorder level
ravenous and it's the and it's the one
time it's truly okay thank you for
saying that it does make me feel sick a
little bit but it is like that Panic
hunger where I'm like what is in the
like what's in the kitchen and I'm
seeting them like grabbing things that I
haven't thought about and that are
expired you know like it is a hunger I
just have not experienced in so long and
you said you ate shrimp for the first
time yes I had shrimp that was my first
like weird pregnancy craving was I just
this kid has taste this kid has taste
there like there's so much of Dave oh
that's so funny Dave is such a seafood
guy like I've never really had shrimp I
which I know is weird but then like I
was thinking about it did it feel like
cannibalism did it feel too close did
you're like it felt very threatening
sometimes were you scared of the shrimp
might actually you come back at me we
have little shrimp Todd got a new fish
tank and he got these little shrimp wait
I would love to see that what that looks
like she's going to drink the whole tank
Annie kill all your babies they're so
little though they're like little babies
yeah he got all these little tiny fish
they're so cute they get big they're not
going to get big we just have a bunch of
little tiny fish oh see C I didn't know
you had fish too we have everything this
I have a zoo I'm an animal handle I'm
going to start charging and BR I going
say when my baby's born can we get a
membership to your zoo guys I when I was
when I did used to do Chelsea Handler
show they had like the list of the
guests because they would do shoot two
shows a day and so they had the list of
the guests for the next one and it said
animal Handler and I thought she had a
brother Nam animal and I was like that's
so weird she a brother Nam
animal no I'm like I want to like teach
kids that snakes are cool and not scary
I like have a whole new this is the Tik
Tok series I love I just like
love this is what I love about Todd he
like he just has all these hobbies that
aren't things that I would naturally be
inclined to and that's so I like I'm
just like learning all these new things
are just now in my world and it's so fun
and I'm like like like we we'll watch
these like YouTubes of these people
these reptile people and then I'm like
dming the what and like I'm like Girling
out with like these like reptile girls
the reptile wives the real reptile Wives
of Los Angeles Giana what's up my girl
she's so cute I have to DM her cuz she
has these like um on the Vlog I saw
today she was wearing these um
sweatpants that are like Hunter print
you know where it's like leaves and
stuff I'm like oh I need Hunter sants
where are you [__] where there and
she would like when I posted my skims
that um the brown skims outfit I got she
was like oh my God I was just going to
get I was like get it [__] it's just
like so cute it's so fun did I tell you
how an ex retaliated by eating my pet
fish I don't like that the same guy it's
the same roast beef guy actually when we
broke up that man in prison like what's
going on he's a really successful guy
understand how every week there's some
new horrifying thing it and she's like
did I tell you and we I'm pretty and we
think she did we go she's like did I
tell you and we're like probably yeah
and then it's
never I miss the tooth fryer guy that
would just knock your teeth out and
steal your teeth oh yeah punch it from I
like the guy that would punch into the
she had a boyfriend that would go he
would punch in he would yeah cuz he
would like stop my I the head of my bed
was facing my window and I think I
forgot to call him one night this was in
high school and so he like opened my
window and then like woke me up with a
punch punched through punched down we
should do like a where are they now with
those guys he's not in a good place yeah
we I I had to uh keep tabs on him
because I think uh he's actually very
unsafe can you tell I've been hanging
out with wealthy people because I'm like
I have to like undo
it you do look extra slouchy today I
have to well I also realized I went up
with a bunch of my girlfriends to Santa
Fe my like um hallucinogen girls and we
rented this like big house and it was so
like Santa Fe is my [__] spot I
[__] love Santa Fe that's where I'm
going to go like write all my [__] you
know we just rented this [__] Mansion
I'm with a bunch of like badass like it
was like me a bunch of PE like women
basically most of them in their 50s just
like inspiring cool [__] I noticed
they were taking pictures and um every
picture I was like my posture was done
like this and I never noticed and I was
like
oh I did that I've created that because
when I was a kid my parents said that I
when I was born I had the best posture
of any baby and they did this whole
photo shoot of me in like gymnastics
gear and stuff cuz I they were like we
just used to laugh about how you just
had the best posture and then it's a
learned behavior I like dimmed my light
physically I like started like it's
called um
armoring yeah so now I'm like I'm back I
thought it was just cuz like the Mary
cadon 2000s era we were all doing that
she was armoring too armoring is a real
thing it's probably why we all have TMJ
because if you've like sustained any
kind of like difficulty or trauma when
you're younger like your first physical
instinct is to armor up so to hunch over
and pull your shoulders off I think I
that's why I think I noticed in traffic
like if I'm late I like this one
shoulder goes up so this is like my like
yeah but I also I was doing a hypnosis a
session of hypnosis and we got to that I
have this story about when I was in
utero I took all my brother's like
nutrients because he was like no offense
a shrimp um and I was like I came out
just like pounds bigger than him so I
that's crazy pounds bigger way bigger
than him and then and then growing up
bigger than him until like 10th grade or
something and then everybody thought me
and my older brother were the Twins and
then um so you felt like shamed about
that so I felt like I took too much so
then I'm always like overgiving it's
like I feel like guilty that I like that
I'm that I have things and so I'm like
I'll just give it to other people and
I'll just like and then so then I was
flying back
from I can't remember where the F maybe
it was Santa Fe and I was like in first
class so there's just two seats so it's
like this guy sitting next to me in the
um I'm in the window and I realized like
it's even like to the point where like I
won't pee if I have to pee like I just
won't do anything that's like even to
bodily functions I won't do anything
that's going to like upset people are
you serious yeah and so and so I'm
sitting on the plane and I'm holding my
piss in and it's like there's so many
more hours left and I'm like ah the
guy's sleeping I don't want to wake him
up and then I was like you know what he
chose leg room over [__] being able
to sleep through this I have to [__]
pee it doesn't matter who is this this
is a stranger so I woke him up I peed he
peed after me it was fine there was
nothing like I probably saved us both
from a UTI but it's like there's so many
times in my life where I like I do that
I put I will put like over my physical
needs this is shocking to me I hate this
I hate that like like I'm glad that
you're seeing it and making change
because the fact that you would sit
there in a [__] first class ticket
that you paid way too much money for I
know because it's very expensive and
like be suffering rise up [__] I'm an
aisle girlly and I know yeah I will I
get up for anybody that's my choice
you're right I chose the aisle I will
get up that like if I'm asleep you wake
me up that's my Duty after that flight
we were on is really one of the funniest
experiences of my life there were two
were there two flights or was that at
the same flight did we fly twice
together I don't know I don't know I
might be confusing when I sat next to
Esther Steinberg just because they the
same I'm over I'm over don't even look
Alik wait can I ask a question first did
you guys get voted anything in high
school yeah um did you they the my high
school was obviously like not a real
high school I got voted hot as tight as
puss by the teachers
um no but um in middle school I remember
being like so annoyed cuz they they just
said most like the Olson twins cuz I had
a twin brother oh that's such a good one
though is it though everybody get one
Annie is that why yeah that's L and I
was like that's not a good enough Todd
was class clown what was yours okay so I
know that I would have gotten most
change since freshman year but it went
to the building because we had a lot of
construction what so I'm really what
wait what this actually I could not it's
like I
I manifested that now for that for you
to get chosen over by a building the
building wait a second this really
explains who you are as a person and
everything about you I was supposed to
get most changed everyone said they
voted for me but also like the fact that
you're like competitive with the
building is very sad very sad very sad
and I did get a different one this is
why you have a movie this is why you had
the the you had the power in your heart
to make a movie because you're trying to
China building was the building on the
ballot like could people vote for the
building or no I think people wrote it
in or the the people who made the
[__] newspaper at our school were
being cool and funny I will the building
did change a lot the we had construction
our whole four years I will say that
what' you get a boob job what was your
big change bch you I was just like two
centimet taller no I just I started out
I mean you guys know this I started my
freshman year with a lesbian sex tape
the football team stole it I was like
you know just drama and then well I
guess that's the wrong choice of word
because then by the end of high school I
was like very serious in the theater
program and I was just not in touch with
like the cool kids anymore I would
rather be talking to a building right
now then hear you brag about your
[__] you [__] asked me but it's so
bad it's not what I thought it's not
what I thought made you made me
humiliate myself are you happy that was
you you did that you were like I was so
serious about theater I'm I'd rather
talk to a beautiful brick wall but I did
get voted most likely to have a talent
agent which I'm like they got that right
they got that right hey thank you but I
still am upset about most changed cuz I
know that it would have been me I got I
got in in swimming I got most improved
in swimming I had a note that allowed me
to not go in the pool you were like I
have a sex tape I can't go they can't
see my body again it'll be too traumatic
for everyone did you get any I don't
remember having I think I recently
reached out to a friend I'm like hey
like can you send me a yearbook from any
of the years I was in high school cuz
similar to yours like I just don't feel
like I had a real high school my high
school was my my yearbook was stapled
together okay there were 17 kids in my
graduate class the girl running the
thing was my friend of me so she was it
was like I was like in one little spot
and then she was like on every [__]
page it was like it's all about the
committee it's all about the I know I
hate that I hate the committee I think
that but what a loser the committee
never likes girls like us they never the
committee they're not looking out for us
it's so funny like that you got compared
to a building and we look like
buildings we have the shoulder structure
of an actual skyscraper I'm actually
really triggered by you guys you're like
a Hut I'm really competitive with you
guys you like a little Hut you were like
a little T you were a little teepe
Esther that building is probably
decrepit now and look at you okay it's a
really nice high school I won't talk
[__] about I was going to say how much
you like your high school it's across
the street from Old Orchard Mall like
reference to Mean Girls wonderful I I've
been back since it's really hard when
they make me sign in and show my ID and
I don't just walk in but um yeah I high
school was I peaked in high school
that's in in mentally I did anyways I
took a a steep fall in high school
but but but my sister and I were
swimmers we were athletes for a school
that hardly even had a a swim team
because we went to Blair high school and
so when my sister and I initially wanted
to go to linat because they had like a
legitimate like high school like swim
program we also swam Club outside of
that but they found out that we were um
we faked our address to go to laata so
we they found out about that and then we
ended up getting zoned to Blair High
School that didn't really have a swim
team and here were two immigrant girls
who they realized like oh my God like
these those shoulders they're like we
can make a
team and so yeah my sister won CIF which
is like California like state
championships like I I won League every
single year and um we never really got
like recognition from the school cuz
they just didn't have the budget or the
money because it was like a really
shitty school but like but um I we never
even got like an announcement no nothing
from them but it's just cuz they didn't
have like their resources for it right
so my sister and I were just known as
like the swimmers that's like
occasionally I you know I I suck to wait
a couple more dicks than I should have
so and I was either the swimmer or like
the the face yeah swallower but that's
that's about it I don't think I ended up
on the yearbook like at all maybe except
for the swimming stuff look at you now
in your shitty sweatpants but you know
can I tell you what hurts is that I am
on the Blair High School list of um
notable like um whatever like but you
know when you click my name it's Bobby's
picture that shows up unbelievable I'm
writing a letter that's funny come on it
is
funny so sadun you became poby Le what a
Tre it has been love you guys we love
you guys and we're two weeks away from
our live show so you can get tickets at
the link below come see us in Los
Angeles February 13th um we can't wa you
better get it's got It's probably sold
out by now so you better go check now
and we'll see you guys next week with a
brand new
[Music]
episode